am montagmorgen kam es gegen 6 55 nahe
des s-bahnhofs hermann straße zu einem
schweren unfall in der siegfriedstraße
im stadtteil neukölln raste der fahrer
eines mitsubishi ungebremst in das heck
eines stehenden linienbus der bvg die
person die im pkw saß ist dabei
eingeklemmt und schwerst verletzt wurden
unsere zuerst eintreffenden kräfte haben
die person dann mittels schere und
spreizer also mit schwerem rettungsgerät
aus dem pkw heraus gerettet wurde eine
reihe von eingeleitet umgehend diese
verlief dann aber im weiteren verlauf
erfolglos so dass die person aus dem pkw
noch auf der einsatzstelle verstorben
ist nach bild informationen rammte der
mitsubishi fahrer zuvor in der
siegfriedstraße mehrere fahrzeuge
der bus war zum zeitpunkt des unfalls
unbesetzt nur die busfahrerin befand
sich im fahrzeug
sie erlitt leichte verletzungen es waren
insgesamt 20 einsatzfahrzeuge der
polizei und feuerwehr an den
rettungsmaßnahmen beteiligt wir sind
bild und wir liefert dir deine news auf
youtube zum nächsten video kommst du
hier und vergesst bitte nicht unseren
kanal zu abonnieren